to help you do this really well because
I encounter students who have lots of
trouble with this it's very important
like I said it very practical skill I
want you to write underneath this
heading a question that does have
anything to do with time ok this is the
question I didn't know just write this
underneath this subject ok now this is
arithmetic yeah because this is
arithmetic with time I want us to
remember the stuff we know about regular
arithmetic and then we'll apply it okay
um how do you do this question what's
the first thing you do yeah yeah the one
of eight which gives you night and then
what do you do you add the 5 and the 7
which gives you 12 so I go one two and
then what's my last thing I had 14 and
two which gives me seventh very good ok
so you guys are really good at doing
this but I want you to actually rewind
for a second and think about what you
were doing ok um you told me to add the
one in 28 those guys those ones in the
eights they have a they have a name
right we call these guys the units we
call them the years and then you added
the 5 and the 7 also has a name what are
those called tens and then lastly you a
dagger the hundreds and if I had a bit
bigger numbers you could obviously
adverse or the ten thousands yo yo yo
good underneath here huh I want you to
write another arithmetic question for me
ok like this
okay because you've demonstrated how
good you are at this right we can apply
the same skills here just like we added
these different things here we couldn't
place value right Tyler's place value as
well right in fact I even label it I'm
gonna do that in column units for tens
I'm going to do the minutes first and if
I need to carry some stuff i will then
I'm going to do the hours okay so 46
plus 17 just think about the numbers 46
plus 17 I think that's 63 right 63 now
when you add in five and seven you said
what 12 so you carried the one right but
you're going to carry ones when you're
doing time right 63 minutes what am I
going to carry out of there I'm gonna
carry 60 minutes right so that leaves me
with three minutes here and those 60
minutes become 0 1 hour over here does
that make sense okay so it looks a bit
different but the concept is the same
and now I can go down here what percent
was two is ten very good ten hours three
minutes that's it okay so make sense
okay we just did an addition I've got a
subtraction here for you here we go
okay again same deals I'm going to apply
the same concept sign you up here down
here now look at this question right in
a similar way to before I need to do
some carrying right but the Canes going
the opposite direction so help me work
out what do i do what i do first look
carefully right I've got ten take away
42 it'll be a problem right I won't stay
with positive numbers so I'm going to
carry something in the opposite
direction yes i'm going to add add from
this for hours i'm going to take an hour
out and add it over here is that make
sense so if i take one of these hours if
I borrow that for a moment okay if I
borrow an hour from that what does it
become over here it becomes 70 right
because it's 60 Plus 10 so this is 70
now now of course you wouldn't say three
hours of 70 minutes because people would
look at us a kind of watch are you
reading okay but this helps us do the
subtraction certainly take away 4228
it's easy to be off by 10 by the way
right so be careful that's done and in
fact over here even though I haven't
written any hours here what that means
it's zero hours isn't it so three
takeaways 03 I get done makes it okay um
last one we did conversion your dinner
riveting what did I say was the last one
rounding okay this will take like two
minutes or if you round it Brandi okay
now you guys are so good at this I'm
just going to give you 3 i'm just going
to go straight to the examples okay so I
want us to write this down round these
three quantities round them to the
nearest hour now i'm going to write the
three quantities down first and then
we're going to look at them and discuss
the briefly okay so i've got this 17
minutes I've got and I've got
okay so obviously you can do this with
minutes or seconds or years or whatever
but it's easy to have a conversation
just like this ok now we ran into the
nearest hour the tricky thing you need
to keep in mind is that just like here
the the place values are a bit different
they're all in 60s 60s rather than like
intense right so when I look at this
seven hours 41 minutes if I saw a number
like 7.41 and I said can you round that
to the nearest unit which way we should
round up round down because it's under
half do you agree with that so now we go
to seven but 41 minutes is that under
half an hour it's over is it so this
should round up so this is going to be
eight hours does that make sense it's
gone up okay what about this one though
five point three hours that's going to
go down that's very obviously going to
go down because it's just like this
right so that is five hours cool the
last one I just want to caution you of
is this one because this is a very
common error okay so please right
underneath this just like I have in
another color okay this does not mean it
does not mean doesn't love me I'll be
really put in capitalism is right it
doesn't mean 30 hours and eight minutes
that's not what it means not right it
means 30 hours and point eight seven
power okay now point over now R is
obviously more than half of it out do
you agree with that because half an hour
is point five of an hour so is this
gonna run up or down 31 hours it's worth
mentioning um you wouldn't normally say
31 hours with you what would you
normally say one day
we can develop in a bit right one day
and seven hours okay I'll notice I've
got gays in here but it's still to the
same accuracy so I've still brand new
tune your sin